do not go to this movie thirsty Rango is
directed by Gore Verbinski directed
Pirates of the Caribbean and the ring so
the man has an idea of what he's doing
and stars the voice talents of Johnny
Depp isla Fisher Bill Nighy Ray Winstone
Abigail Breslin Alfred Molina and
Timothy Olyphant among more so we have a
pretty wide range of talent going on
here and when I saw the trailer for this
movie I was just thinking man that looks
different I mean the first thing I
thought was my gosh that looks different
right now is a lizard who aspires to be
an actor yes that's right he wants to be
a thespian in fact when they said that
in the movie some young girl next to me
was like what be very careful we want to
be an actor and you tell someone you
want to be a thespian be very careful
about the pronunciation that word and he
gets lost in the desert discovers this
town called dirt where they were very
dirt and they have a problem they have
hardly any water at all they're in the
middle of a drought they have about five
days worth of water left and Rango
wanting to be an actor decides to put on
this whole show that he's this
incredible killer guy who's like seeing
all types of wars and he's like this
hardened guy who's like killed a ton of
people
he's just like the greatest lizard ever
and he puts on this whole show and
everyone kind of buys into it and they
make him the sheriff of that town and
then everyone looks to him for hope to
find this water that is supposedly out
there that can bring their town hope
again this movie is absolutely
hysterical I was cracking out so much
during this movie Johnny Depp's voice
acting is out of this world good they
really need to create a category in the
Oscars for best voice actor because this
is a talent that people have it's not
just sitting behind a mic this it takes
a lot of talent and Johnny Depp oh my
word he is so good in this movie he does
all these whole
various quirky things with the lizard
that just ah I thought about it I
thought really hard about this because I
don't want to say something like this
and then you know realize that I might
have been wrong this is probably the
best CGI animation I have ever seen I
can't think of a CG animation movie it
looks this beautiful there are shots
what I was like is that real or is that
fake I mean it was like so well done the
little creatures each little individual
fur you know moving a different time
that just how do they do it I don't even
understand crazy good the best part of
this movie by far is the quirky humor
it's just so different from the average
children's movie and you know what
I wouldn't recommend this movie to
children this isn't really a children's
film that I mean there's a lot of adult
humor in this film there is swearing in
it and there's a lot of scary parts I
mean I wouldn't I want to know maybe 11
to 12
I don't know and over this isn't really
a children's movie so and a lot of the
humor is not going to be understood by
children this is just so different and
that's what I love about it I'm so used
to the same kind of stuff in children's
films no this is just a really different
movie and I love it for that the lizard
had so many hilarious little things a
giant that gave to it like he would
always just kind of mumble he was trying
to hide the fact that he was like this
kind of really like a shrimpy little
lizard but he was putting on this show
that he was this amazing guy and people
wouldn't stand up to him sometimes even
but it's just so funny it's a little uh
isn't such a great character I loved it
honestly I can't think of hardly Jimmy
flaws I had this film I'm going to give
it three and a half out of four stars
and the only reason not giving it four
stars is pure entertainment value I
can't think of too many flaws of this
movie it's not a four-star movie to me
like an inception or Star Wars or
something I really recommend that you
see Rango like I said not a children's
movie though and that's also something I
loved about it because it was just you
know it pushed the boundaries it gave it
an edge you know what I mean like it
just ah si Rango the music oh my gosh I
forgot to say Hans Zimmer's scores so
good
there's it always cuts to these four
little owls we're like singing and
Mexican style and playing guitar about
they sing the story kinda like in babe
another good movie if you haven't seen
that anyway
Rango three and a half out of four stars
loved Rango check it out definitely see
when it comes out so Rango is a lizard
new start the move so Rango is a lizard
who aspires to be an actor so Rango is a
lizard Rango is a lizard hooted Rango is
a lizard who with rank a little bit oh
my gosh